[Music]
this
is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as
the status symbol of choice this hour is
dedicated to what has been called
the greatest legal fraud
in america today
timeshares timeshares
you've heard me talking about timeshares
and if you're a current timeshare owner
or you are a former timeshare owner
and you want to talk today is your day
the phone number is triple eight
eight two five five
we'd like to hear from you maybe you
worked for or do work for
these scumburgers and you want to tell
what really goes on
behind the curtain pay no attention to
the men behind the curtain
right mikey yeah mikey is mike flasky
the ceo
of diamond international
one of the three largest timeshare
providers
in the world and by far one of the
scummiest
so mikey and i have had interaction on
twitter he calls me davey by the way
[Laughter]
it's a it's a mutual lovely affair we
have going
so if you want to take our uh survey we
would love to hear from you if you also
are a time share owner or former owner
uh text to timeshare to 33 789 we're
doing a research project
on how dissatisfied the customers are
and if you're satisfied that's fine tell
the truth
maybe you love your timeshare that would
make you statistically unusual
but um that's fine we'd love to hear
from you one i want actually
real data on what's really going on out
there in the real world not from
timeshare world not from uh somewhere
else university of
central florida did a survey that said
87 of the people they surveyed hate
their timeshare
they felt like they got ripped off how
do you stay in business when 87
of your customers think you screwed them
let me that
let me just tell you there is nothing
greedier and hungrier than a timeshare
salesman
when you make this bargain effectively
what you're doing
is the zookeeper comes up and says hey
we'll give you a free pass to the zoo
for a year
but all you gotta do is go into the
tiger cage and sit and pet the tiger for
two hours
by the way the tiger's not eating in
three days he might be a bit hungry
he might be a little greedy
and so you're supposed to go into the
tiger cage and pet the tiger for three
hours
and then you get a free pass to the zoo
if you survive no one does
very few people get out of the tiger
cage alive
most of them get eaten and you know what
eating means
now you're a time chair owner oh joyful
you've been screwed that's what this
amounts to
you want to talk about timeshares
obviously i'm going to be doing that for
the next
oh 45 minutes or so you jump in the
phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five i wanna
hear from you
this
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes
you are the next greatest generation
because you
have proven that even in adversity that
you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
so hilton is buying
diamond international
for 1.4 billion dollars
hilton you're going to screw up your
brand
several of the shareholders at hilton
are
objecting to the purchase and
there's some activist shareholders that
are jumping out there trying
to block the purchase it's not closed
yet it should close in august
i think the hilton board is going to go
ahead with it because they've got their
heads stuck
up their timeshare because all they see
is how much
money diamond makes but they don't
realize the brand damage they're going
to do to the wonderful name of hilton
sad i wonder if enough of you
stockholders at hilton actually raised
your hand and said we don't want to own
scummy stuff if they would actually
stop the deal that'd be interesting
debbie is in el paso debbie tell me your
time share story
hi dave well speaking of helsin
that is who i bought my time share from
hilton
grand vacations oh
back in 2018.
in las vegas
suckered into going to a presentation
for of course a free
weekend in vegas all expenses paid and
all of the good stuff they try to throw
in
um we were promised a cruise
as well which we never took and uh
we went to the timeshare
we had um our two boys with us that
at the time were i think 12 and 15 years
old
and they stayed back at the room while
we went to the presentation
and we were there probably at least
three hours
and our our presenter
um you know after meddling into our
lives he found out we were christian
and he kept throwing christian scripture
after scripture at us how god wanted to
bless us
and god's blessings were abundant and we
should bless
ourselves and our family with this great
vacation home
and uh we ended up doing it
unfortunately how much did you pay for
it
um well the total price on our contract
was
almost 35 000
and they were adamant about
well we have this great offer american
express is teaming up with us
hilton and we are offering this credit
card you guys can put
8 000 down on it and you get extra
points right away
and everything will be great
so we signed up for the credit card put
a thousand
on that card right away and they
um swooped us off to a different room to
sign papers
and this and that and and then
uh they took us on a bus ride to
a condo that was supposed to be exactly
excuse me exactly like our condo that we
just purchased
supposedly
it was a a great place it was
overlooking vegas with
all the fancy things it had was like i
think a five-bedroom
suite and had pop-up tvs and
every amenity you can think of and they
just
told you you know you can invite your
family and friends and
come to vegas on the new year's eve and
so we were pretty excited about it until
we
got home and you know we
we thought okay well let's see if we can
book this place
for new year's and of course no
that's not available it's been booked
out for
years and you only have a certain window
that you can stay at one of our places
which
we didn't know at the time oh wait a
minute
so they lied to you oh yeah
oh okay just making sure just making
sure we're clear that hilton
grand vacations lied to debbie in el
paso
okay i'm just making sure we get that
straight they did lie
and yeah in fact they said it wasn't a
time share this is a vacation
opportunity and you can vacation not
only in vegas
but you can vacation all over the world
and go to different places
and have new experiences
and uh you know after a couple of months
of paying our monthly payments and
trying to get a
even just to go to vegas back to vegas
they had nothing available except maybe
a one bedroom
place that wasn't even the location that
we
saw and uh you know that's when we said
okay we've been had and
we're not gonna we're not gonna do this
anymore and
we had heard about your timeshare exit
um the people that
you share with people online and so we
contacted them
and after about a year and a half of
going through
dealings with the timeshare exit people
we uh we got released oh they got you
out
good yes good they got about 20 000
people out so that's good
oh yeah yeah they did get us out
way to go so that that was uh but that
cost money too of course
they charged you two or three thousand
dollars for that right oh it was more
than that
was it okay uh but you got out you got
out of a 27 000
loan and you had to pay the 8 000 credit
card debt i'm sure
yes yes but we're out and
we will never do that again well for
that matter you probably won't even go
into a hilton again
like for a hotel still anything that
says hilton on it after you got kicked
in the teeth that bad you're not going
to want to do business with
yeah exactly wow i'm so sorry
well thank you for sharing your story so
your advice your advice obviously is
don't go to the presentation
do not go don't go don't go for the free
vacation don't go to the presentation
and whatever they say you can tell
they're lying if their mouth is moving
yes exactly don't don't even listen yeah
debbie thank you for calling and sharing
your story jonathan has a story he's in
richmond virginia
jonathan tell me your time share story
hey dave how are you today
better than i deserve what's up
fantastic so
this is a story about getting out of the
lion cage or the tiger cage with my
limbs intact
all right so you made it this is this is
wild this is almost sounds like a movie
and i swear it's true
so my wife had found something online
about if we went to this
presentation down in williamsburg
virginia that we would get free
airline tickets and a hotel room to use
anytime we wanted and we're like okay
that sounds pretty good
so we go down to this thing and we get
put into this room with and i don't know
what company it was it might have been
wingate i'm not sure i don't remember
about four or five years ago
and we got put into this room and this
guy comes
running into the room and he goes oh my
gosh guys i'm so sorry the normal person
who does these presentations isn't here
today
so i'm gonna do your presentation but
i'm sorry i'm not used to doing them so
it's going to be kind of
kind of winging it and we're like oh
okay yeah whatever
we're eating our granola bars and
drinking our orange juice that they
provided and you know we're like cool
whatever
and so he launches into this thing and
the first thing they show us is a
presentation
and the very first five minutes is that
first scene and
up remember where they if you've seen
the movie where the
uh he meets his wife and they go through
their life and she passes away and it's
heartbreaking right
so their whole push is it's about
family and your well-being and enjoying
your life which by the way
showing a video clip like that that's
copyrighted would be illegal
exactly and that's one thing we kind of
look at that's a
whole other ball game but anyway so he
gets off he
stops the video because his mom calls
him the dude's mom
calls on the middle of his presentation
oh it's amazing and he answers the phone
and really she's like should i answer
it's my mom and she he puts it on
speaker
and this woman on the other end i say
woman because there's a
we we question that later on my wife and
i are like i don't think so
like she talks about her ailments and
stuff and anyway
we go to this woman um they send us off
in these individual
um i'll tell you what man i want to hear
the rest of this this is fabulous i'm
gonna put you on hold we're gonna talk
about it after the break
it's a time share special hour talking
to real people with real experiences
[Music]
[Music]
still on baby step number one how'd you
guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit chministries.org budget
don't worry it's worth it
[Music]
we're talking about the what has
arguably been called
the largest legalized fraud in america
today
time shares and the crazy extremes these
people go through
to sell them we're talking with jonathan
in richmond virginia and he starts
telling a story of a guy who busts in to
do the sales
presentation claims he had to show up
and do it because but he's never done it
before she's not going to be very good
at it gets his mom
on the phone while he's on stage because
he's talking about
how important it is to your family to
have a vacation together
and that's where we left jonathan off so
the mo that's obviously not his mom on
the phone
yeah that's honestly when my wife and i
went to leave
we sat in our car and literally laughed
at the whole the whole experience
because it was like that movie ten men
or ten yeah ten men those guys richard
dreyfuss remember that
and they're selling aluminum siding
it's it's it was like a movie i'm
telling you dave it was wild because it
gets even better
so if you're ready let's let's finish
this puppy up the rest of our experience
so we
this guy finishes up and they then send
all the couples so this is about 25
couples each with an individual
representative
to show us the property and how
beautiful it was let me tell you dave
the property was not that beautiful it
was probably about as nice
as the old apartment complex my wife and
i lived in when we got married oh i had
one of those yeah i did that oh gross
gross so anyway so she
go meet our rep is this young lady
probably about you know late twenties
and we go she's like oh it's a big
property let me go in my van
so we go to her van and it has european
license plates on it which i'm like okay
that's and i recognize that right away
having lived in a foreign country for a
while
i'm like okay that's weird it's hard to
bring a car into this country from
another country um
okay whatever and she's like yeah my
husband was military and he recently
left me
and i'm single mom now and she's like
she's the booster seats and all the toys
and the mess in the car
we're like okay sure so we get in and
she drives us around look at this
property and we
go blah blah blah we come back to
the the finishing room kind of like
they're they're they're
where they gather everyone at individual
table and we sit there with her
and she just drills into us the costs
and
what do we like about this and we're
we're not we're stone-faced we're
sitting there going uh-huh
okay cool can we get out of here now and
no
no no we're telling them now or this
isn't working for us and they could
then they bring in the big guns so this
guy comes over
and says hey what do we need to do for
this
and what price point can we give you he
starts breaking it down
by day how much it will cost us by day
and we're like oh my gosh you guys are
kidding me and this guy has a sob story
too like
oh it's so important to your family i
had uh stage three cancer and i
feed it and i had pictures to prove it
of me and
i had i not done this it would have
ruined my family or like oh my gosh just
get us out of here and so we finally
just said you know what
no we're done give us what we came for
and they finally relented and the lady
who took us around the sweet
young girls like oh what a shame you
don't care about your family and we're
like yeah whatever
we just we actually we actually did get
two free airline tickets and a free
hotel night and we used it to go
to new orleans for free we actually did
get something out of it
and the guy who even gave it to us said
oh that's a really good perk he said
it's a shame you didn't take this are
you sure
you don't want this great um product and
we're like oh my goodness get us out of
here
and my wife and i we got in the car we
laughed and felt like we need to take a
shower afterwards because it was felt
that slimy it was awful
so now the big question is you you got
out alive
and you got and you got a great story
out of it because this is just it's so
it's the it's so ridiculous that it is
kind of comedic
but that is their model i mean this is
who these people are
now would you do it again for airline
tickets absolutely not
no we have the money we're going to pay
cash it wasn't worth it no it wasn't
worth it so yeah your advice is even
though you got out of the tiger cage
alive your advice is
don't pet the tiger i love it all right
troy is with us troy
is in columbia south carolina troy tell
me your time share story
hey dave thanks for taking the call sure
um
wow we started back in 2008 um
my wife was going to the beach and i was
to join them later on during the week
um we officially bought the world's most
expensive
beach portraits um
that was the the catch to get us in i
guess you would say
you're taking a picture of you on the
beach and this is
this is this is the prize that's it
yeah 24 000 later
the lions and tigers and sharks ripped
us apart
which company was this this is wonderful
westgate
westgate all right and you were aware
myrtle beach myrtle beach all right
westgate and myrtle beach you should get
a beach portraiture go pet the tiger
you buy a twenty four thousand dollar
timeshare in myrtle beach
yeah yeah and this 2008 so you still got
it
we still have it it's paid for we want
to get out of it
um you know every time we go somewhere
every time we go on vacation we can't
seem to get
the week that we want to go and you know
it's always booked up you might have to
book two months out from the date that
we want
um you know it's almost as if you would
ask for the wrong date you would get the
one you wanted
yeah maybe so how many times have you
actually
used it used it
every year since 2009.
okay but never on the date that you
wanted it
correct yeah okay yeah well we're not
gonna get it
i have my wife here with me too her
name's tanya so
you hear her in the background yeah
what'd she say
[Laughter]
so has the uh has the property
maintenance fees gone up through this
time
oh yeah every year goes up um
it was you know when we first started
out the property maintenance fees
weren't so bad
but we were shown the model of what the
site was going to look like uh new
buildings
parking garage swimming pool on top of
buildings
um they have the model still in the
resort and they selling it
they still sell it to uh they're still
selling the model and they never built
it since 2009.
that is correct sir and that's what you
were promised that's fraud
that's that's what i've been saying not
to mention the fact that they held our
kids for six hours
um wouldn't bring them back to us until
we finally said
fine just whatever here let me sign the
paper and let me get my kids back please
yeah um it was a mess
and it still is every year we get told
we're vip people y'all must be very
important well i
told my wife i said i think i've figured
out what vip stands for is very ignorant
people and
we fell victim to them even though we
tried we tried hard not to
they just they were relentless they
relentless man i appreciate you having a
sense of humor and being willing to tell
your story because it's hard to tell a
story when you mess up
i tell my mess-up story all the time and
i've gotten used to telling it but
uh man when you pay stupid tax it hurts
it really is 24
000 and basically you've gotten
a handful of weeks out of it and really
you with what you paid in maintenance
fees alone you could have rented the
hotel for that right
absolutely absolutely yeah but a secret
for a long time because we were pretty
embarrassed that we fell for it
oh yeah a shame we didn't want anybody
knowing we're gonna have to build
we're gonna have to have dr john deloney
build a timeshare buyers
support group i'm sorry
so we're gonna have to have dr deloney
build a time share buyer support group
my name is troy and i bought a timeshare
that's right this is right yeah
oh my gosh we're looking to try to get
rid of it we've been contacted by
uh west financial group which is a
lawyer
that wants to help a little bit pricey
and we had a j t solutions call us
um i i don't know enough about these
places but i don't want to get scammed
again
yeah um so you know i'm being very
cautious
yeah i know the wesley folks i don't
know j t and i don't know enough about
the
uh either one of them to to endorse
either one of them but i don't blame you
for checking it out that's for sure so
hey man thanks for calling in we
appreciate you sharing
with us you know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
one of the other interesting phenomenons
that has happened with the timeshare
people is
attorneys are occasionally
contacted by time share owners and like
that last guy
where they've been straight up you know
we promised you a building this model
and 10 years later they've not built the
building
so that would be under the heading of
fraud
which is an actual thing by the way and
your timeshare people don't seem to know
that but it's an actual thing fraud is a
thing
and uh fraud is a reason to get
contracts invalidated
in court always if you were defrauded
then the contract can be
easily set aside in court so attorneys
often will take a case like that and
contact the timeshare company and the
timeshare company will go oh okay and
they just let them out but they wouldn't
let the people out before but
you get an attorney involved well if an
attorney does that too many times the
timeshare people get pissed off
and what's happened is they've put this
concerted effort to put the attorneys
out of business
so they sue the attorney
that has been getting people out
and bury him in legal costs and
discovery challenges and everything else
to where
a small practice attorney you know three
four person attorney office
can get run out of business by get by
them being sued
even though they didn't do anything
wrong but it's just they just bury you
in legal costs because the timeshare
business they make billions of dollars
billions with a b and so to
chase down some attorney one of the
attorneys several of the attorneys that
have been sued
got together and hired an attorney so as
a group
now they are countersuing again and
trying to stop the timeshare business
from doing this to them because several
of them have been run out of business
one of the guys that got sued regularly
by them is a guy named scott montgomery
he's an attorney in missouri
and uh that's a true story about what
happened to you wasn't this guy didn't
run you out of business but they tried
they sure did dave they're they're
trying the best their best but
we're hanging in there we had a
a hearing yesterday down in the federal
court in
in florida on our motion for an
injunction to try and stop this
sham litigation against attorneys
who represent timeshare owners did it go
well
i i think it i think it did dave you
know the the judge is
is a scholar of the law and if we don't
win on this
motion i know that we will ultimately
prevail on the merits but you know
these timeshare pushers they're like
drug dealers
we hear from our many clients you know
that
that they have even divorced they've
they've separated from their spouse
because of the financial
ruin caused by these timeshare pushers
i know of one man who who lived by
your advice dave he never had a debt
that he didn't pay he was a hard-working
man and he paid
his debts until he went into the
tiger cage and when he came out of the
tiger cage
he had more debt than he could handle
and you know what happened to him
the timeshare pusher they published a
notice
for all of the world to see that they
were foreclosing upon him
and they said this man could not pay his
debt and he
was so embarrassed he was so ashamed
that that he took his own life oh my god
he took
he committed suicide after he went into
the tiger cage
so if you think that you can go into the
tiger cage
because you want two free knights or the
body snatchers got to you
and you're gonna come out on the other
end okay
well you're wrong yeah you're wrong
so you've been pretty regularly uh
suing the timeshare business and getting
people out that's why they're pissed at
you and suing you
trying to count trying to bury you uh
what is most
how many people have you gotten out can
you say is that is that something you
can talk about
sure sure we've been doing this for
several years
we've gotten out about 1500 people
we represent about 17 000 people in a
class action against blue green
and we are working for many other
defrauded mostly elderly people to try
and get them out
as we speak so out of the out of the
one-offs not the class action but the
one-offs um
what is the typical uh
reason from a legal perspective
that they would you know that basically
you're saying you did this
you're you're accusing them of
wrongdoing of some kind
what is the typical wrongdoing that
causes them to bow and release the
consumer
well dave there are dozens of different
timeshare pushers in this country
some are more reasonable than others and
some will negotiate
a settlement with you when you point out
that
look you're your timeshare salesperson
that that felon that you employed to sit
across the table from
a buyer they committed fraud
they committed negligent
misrepresentation
they violated a state unlawful
merchandising practices
act or you charge them illegal document
preparation fees when
when we point out how they have violated
the law
a reasonable time share company
will often negotiate a settlement others
will not negotiate a settlement and you
have to go to litigation
you have to go to arbitration you have
to file a class action
and it's extremely difficult you know
these timeshare pushers they like to
sell
their finance backed securities every
year to wall street banker types
you know wyndham sells hundreds of
millions of dollars of timeshare
mortgages
to wall street bankers so if you're one
of those people who agreed to
sign a timeshare mortgage to to finance
the purchase of your timeshare
it's a whole lot harder for me to get
you out of your timeshare obligation
than if you're a person who just
financed it who just paid out of pocket
and who's paid in full who's current on
their maintenance fees
it's much easier for a lawyer to
negotiate
a settlement for that person who is
known in the industry as paid in full
yeah well because they no longer in like
that example with windom you said they
are or westgate who was it they sold
anyway they're they're packaging them
together they're selling them on hedge
funds
much like a mortgage-backed security
except there's no mortgage because
there's no actual real estate they're
selling air
but these are basically unsecured loans
but they don't own the loan anymore
and you go to them and say you committed
fraud and they go yeah i know but we've
sold the loan
so you got to deal with hedge fund
company over here
that now owns the loan and you can't get
that forgiven
because that company hadn't done
anything wrong they just bought bad
papers the only thing they did wrong
you're exactly right dave and the
insidious thing that is going on here
i'm sure you know more about dodd-frank
than i do but that was the law that was
passed by our united states congress to
try
and deal with the uh subprime home
lending crisis back in 2008. well the
timeshare pushers
got together and they lobbied congress
and they got an exclusion
for themselves where dodd-frank does not
apply
to timeshare mortgages so they're doing
the same thing
they're engaging in the same tactics
with the same
big banks that occurred back in 2008 and
caused a
home lending crisis that's going on now
in the timeshare space because they had
one
captive congressman from down in florida
and he snuck the word time shared
mortgage
into an exclusion from dodd-frank
so they can prey on unsuspecting
consumers
who have zero ability to repay
and sell them time shares and sell them
a mortgage
and dodd-frank doesn't apply to them
now they can make knowingly make a bad
loan and then sell that loan in bulk
those those bad loans in bulk to hedge
funds
and uh they put them on the books
looking for a great rate of return and
and of course if the ti if the consumer
doesn't pay it's not windham or westgate
or diamond then that's calling them it's
the hedge fund
that bought the loan that's who they now
owe the money to and that's who's going
to sue them if they don't pay on their
timeshare right
that's exactly right dave that's what's
going on and our government
needs to fix it and god bless you dave
for being a champion for all of these
people who have been defrauded by these
timeshare pushers
thank you scott scott montgomery from
missouri he's an attorney there that has
successfully removed 1500 people and has
17
000 in a class action suit on blue green
right now
wow this is a nasty nasty space
when you get in a room with those people
you really do feel like you need to take
a shower
when you're done look
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's
the ramsey show where debt is dumb cash
is king
and the paid off home mortgage has taken
the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host christy wright ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author
is my co-host today open phones as we
answer your questions about your life
and your money the phone number here
triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five sam's with us in new
york city to start off this hour
hey sam how are you i'm doing well it's
a pleasure to speak to you
you too what's up that's great
quick question for you i am newly
married i am expecting our first child
god willing in about advice
yay thank you um
we have about 50 combined about 50 or 60
thousand dollars sitting in an account
jointly between our two accounts
uh about 16 000 so far in some like
10 000 is in like the s p 500 and 6 000
mutual funds that my wife had before we
got married i have about
28 000 dollars sitting in canada and
some investments i'm originally canadian
my question to you is with this 50 60
000
which by the way this is including the
uh emergency fund we didn't like split
it out yeah just sitting in an account
uh my question to you is to take that
money to put it into
real estate as opposed to the market i
know you're a big fan of
mutual funds
okay do you have any debt no you're that
oh that's cool good for you well um
i'm a big fan of having a huge pile of
cash when a baby's on the way
and when baby comes and baby and mommy
are okay and you come home
then we kind of push play on what we
call
our baby steps and uh so if you're
debt-free
then your first baby step would be to
set aside use as you said the emergency
fund i'd carve some of that out
and christy we always say three to six
months of expenses
yeah and i think one of the cool things
is you guys already have
this in place before the baby comes a
lot of people are trying to stockpile
cash for
a baby and you're already there and so
once the baby's here and healthy
then you can put any of that extra on
your investments maybe four baby steps
four or five and six paying off the
house do you guys own your home
okay so we're renting we're renting now
i mean we're the planets to buy in the
next couple years so you're saying is to
wait it out the next
until after my wife gives birth yeah
just hold on to that
yeah just hold on to the cash because
it's just good to have that extra
cushion when you're bringing a baby into
the world just for any
unexpected medical expenses that type of
thing and then
whatever your next goal is if your next
goal is to
buy a house at some point then some of
that can go into savings to save up for
a down payment on a house so really just
the baby steps are there to guide you
what the goals should be
but where you are with having your
emergency fund and then
you know your investments and so on then
you can start looking at that that goal
of saving for a house as well
got it and you think our emergency plan
should be a little bigger being that
my weights on maternity leave she's not
going to be working the next couple
months and she stopped working a couple
weeks ago just wanted her
to like have a lot of shields coming up
to the delivery can you make it on your
income
so i'm self-employed i know can you make
it on your income
i think anywhere between 600 to 3 000
a week so it's like a little nerve
wrecking like it hit me last night a
little bit but uh today
next two days and i'm making like almost
two grand so well
realistically during the time your wife
is on
maternity leave can you make it on your
income
i should be able to yeah okay then you
shouldn't need the emergency fund it
shouldn't come up
i think i think you can i think you're
just being a new daddy worrywart which
means you're which means you're a good
dad okay
you're concerned about your family
that's a good thing but i i think you're
going to do it i think you're going to
bust it and make sure that you make
enough to live on
while she's on maternity leave and you
won't need to touch it but i would have
a fully funded emergency fund
and i would set the rest of the money
aside
for my house fund and then i would begin
putting 15 percent of my income away
in retirement in good mutual funds but i
think you're fine to park that money for
for real estate for a purchase but no i
would not buy real estate as an
investment right now
i think you're saving for your first
home a big down payment above your
emergency fund
and that's how i'm going to start
allocating this stuff out well that's
the reason too that we even
suggest a range for your emergency fund
three to six months different people
have different comfort levels different
uh incomes and so if it gives you more
comfort sam to have a six-month
emergency fund instead of three months
and
you can do that as well if it gives you
peace of mind yeah i would do that but i
again i would do that and plan not to
use it yeah
plan a plan to live on your income yeah
because this is all we know this is all
coming
jeff's with us in cape cod hi jeff
welcome to the ramsay show
hey how we doing today better than i
deserve what's up
excellent so uh just trying to find
out kind of what you would do in my
situation or if i'm handling this uh
correctly uh back in october
my uh wife wanted a divorce
and uh left leaving me with
the house two dogs and two children
as they stayed home dad for the last
three years
wow she uh then
uh lied in court and got awarded the
house
resulting in me and the children having
to leave
with no income and no job uh
i've since started a handyman home
improvement business
and i have about four thousand dollars
saved
but i'm having trouble finding an
apartment
or and i definitely can't get a mortgage
so kind of just looking to see what you
would do
why are you having trouble finding an
apartment um
one just getting call backs from real
estate agents or
landlords two they need um
they're requiring pay stub which
i don't have because i'm self-employed
for they rent apartments all the time to
self-employed people
is there a place to find those
i don't i've never had the rent before
i've always i've been able to buy a home
until now
uh is the only place i know is you know
apartments.com or zillow
yeah well no i mean you make a list of
the rental properties in the area
uh off of several different sites that
you can find
and you call them one at a time and you
call the real estate agent that's
involved one at a time
and you make a list of the apartments in
the area and you start calling them one
at a time you don't have to go through
zillow you don't have to go through a
website
or apartments.com you can just look up
and go there's an apartment right over
there i'm gonna call those people
there's one over there i'm gonna call
those people
and there's one over there and i'm going
to call those people and just sit and
you don't have anything more important
to do than to get you and the kids off
the street that's your number one goal
right yeah we currently live in a
camper at a campground i picked it up
for a hundred bucks
that's the beginning of the spring um
the best thing i could think of at the
time yeah
um jeff jeff i just i just hear fear in
your voice
and listen exactly like you can do this
listen
you can do this you're going to start
looking at the apartments one at a time
you're going to take one step at a time
you're scared but you can do this
how old are your kids two and three
okay yeah the three-year-old's gonna
write a best-selling book
that when he's extremely successful it
talks about the time
that he lived in a camper and how he
and his dad came all the way back from
that it's going to be a great story
now go ride it
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text and
six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over 70 dollars
a month by switching
to pure top just go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is
our co-host today
open phones eight at five five
two two five at some point every
business owner has to stop daydreaming
about their business idea and actually
go
do it uh once you're working hard to
grow your business you'll need advice
about how to take it to the next level
no matter which
stage you're in you can make money doing
what you love
and the business boutique conference
will show you how to make it happen
october 14th through the 16th i will
join
a lineup of rockstar speakers including
christy wright anthony o'neil jasmine
starr nona jones and bianca
oltof you got it and i'm making sure i
said that right and
walk you through all the different ways
you can build your business starting and
running a business is a big deal
we'd love to have you we've been doing
this event this business boutique event
for many years christy is a rock star
and uh three day event in person in
nashville
89 or guess what you can also look at
the live stream
text boutique to 33 789
boutique 233 789
christie this event has a
different level of energy that's an
understatement
i don't know if it's because it's all
women and there really is something
about that crowd that the fact that it's
a
women's conference is so it feels safe
but it's also exciting
and what's cool is you have a variety of
people represented in the crowd
it's some small businesses some side
businesses some women are running
you know uh medium small medium-sized
teams
you've got home-based hobby business you
know you got non-profits you got
everybody in there but they're all
moving forward chasing their dream
trying to figure out how to do this
thing and we give them the tools
and the solutions to do that talk about
marketing money
social media all those things that they
need help with
october 14th through the 16th business
boutique in nashville 89
text boutique to 33 789
boutique to 33789 our question today
comes from blinds.com they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee that means even
if you mess up if you mismeasure you
pick the wrong color like i've done
before
they'll remake your window blinds for
free this is a great company
free samples free shipping new promos
all the time
blinds.com use the promo code ramsey
today's question comes from matthew in
south carolina i'd love your opinion and
tips on how to start a cleaning business
i work a full-time job making 38 000
before taxes
i've always had a niche for cleaning and
want to start my own business
i have no clue about where to start what
to save up how to apply for business
loans
etc i have no debt and i'm on baby step
three
i'd appreciate any help you can give me
what's interesting about this question
dave is
i get a similar question often which is
this idea that you've got to have this
big huge savings account you've got to
apply for loans you've got to do all
this stuff to start a business look
get you some cleaners and start cleaning
get some cleaning supplies
reach out to people start cleaning in
your neighborhood start word of mouth
post on your facebook page get a little
bit scrappy matthew in south carolina
and start doing this thing on the side
you do not need business loans not for
any business but especially not for this
business
and you can start really small with the
cash that you have to get some cleaning
supplies and start doing this it doesn't
have to be a big deal
yeah this is um what we've done matthew
here
it started on a card table in my living
room um
coming up on 30 years ago and
never borrowed money 100
we took what we had and went and made
some money with it and we took that
money
and grew the business and took what we
had
and we made some money with it and
that's called organically
growing your business meaning the money
that's here
is the money we use to grow this
business and it has worked
all the way up to where we are today and
so
uh and it can start with a bottle of 409
and some rags that's right that's right
of all businesses this is a very easy
business that you want to do to start
small with what you have with some cash
on your hand yeah and the trick is to
get the first job yeah
and then they give you money and you
take that money and you can upgrade your
supplies your tools
and some printed materials or a business
card or whatever you want to do
and then you take that money from that
next job and you can grow a little bit
more
and then you get to actually start
making some money beyond your costs
and you keep adding revenue and the
revenue
is what you use to grow this business
with nothing else yep
uh a business alone in this situation uh
not what
would be ludicrous that's what's uh
christie's saying and she's exactly
right
so we're gonna avoid that at all costs
chuck is with us in orlando hi
chuck how are you i'm doing great miss
ramsey it's a pleasure to speak with you
you too what's up well i was just
wondering if you could um
well personally just qualify by saying
thank you guys so much for the advice
that you give
um you guys have helped our family so
much me and my wife are so grateful
we're actually debt-free we
paid our home off wow no debt whatsoever
thank you so much um but i was wondering
if you could just speak into a little
bit
that feeling of i don't know if you call
it restlessness or
you know kind of to me i i i kind of
define it by saying
you feel like you're drowning in a sea
of options a little bit once you're
debt-free and i know it's a wonderful
problem to have but
for us it's just felt um at least for
the past several months since we paid
our home off and officially became debt
free that we
are kind of looking for what to do next
and we're kind of a little bit fearful
you know
the purpose is so baked in when you're
you know gazelle intense you're paying
off debt you're paying off debt you're
frugal
it changes a lot of things about your
life and
you know for us we're very happy to be
where we are we definitely are very
grateful
but we just seem to be a little stuck on
kind of kind of what to do next
i'm so curious your answer to this dave
because i was just talking to a friend
about this the other day
where she was saying someone had said
once you become completely debt free
it's almost a
uh you struggle to find what's the next
goal what what do you talk to people
about that that's so interesting
well you need a goal that's what you
need and because that's what's missing
you had a goal it was very clearly
defined it was right in front of you
in this case it was the villain the debt
you're trying to kill the villain right
and uh but now we get to switch gears
and we go from villain as a goal to
prosperity as a goal
and generosity is a goal and so
there's three things you can do with
money and you need to be doing all three
and you need to be doing them in writing
and on purpose towards a goal
and number one is uh you know generosity
number two
is investing and number three is uh
is just you know lifestyle enjoying fun
and so i have a goal to take a trip and
spend uh
three weeks in africa or three weeks in
australia
which i've done both of um in the last
three four years
um you know the uh have a goal of
buying a lake house uh these are these
are lifestyle things you're gonna do and
you start saving towards that goal
put a number on it and it becomes the
part that portion of your budget that
you're putting towards fun or lifestyle
you go towards that
i have a goal of uh you know
building an orphanage i have a goal of
uh i had a goal that was pretty cool
i i i saw a guy one time he told me he
had given away
uh that year he had given away a million
dollars and i thought
man that was pretty cool and i did that
and then okay now what am i going to do
because i climbed that mountain now what
are you going to do i said i want to
give a million dollars in one day
and then i was able to do that like
you're before last year yeah so
uh with with the christmas presents we
gave to our team
and some support to for a local
orphanage and some other things we did
we were able in one day in one morning
we gave away a million dollars so
you know you got to have uh something
that just go okay i'm gonna go this is
my new thing i'm gonna go for that
and i'm gonna go for that and and on the
investing side
uh uh i just i keep up with net worth
just because uh not because i i'm
building bigger barns or something but
but it's just a way i got to keep score
somewhere on my goal
and so you know you hit a net worth of a
million dollars and you want to hit a
net worth of 5 million dollars and
you want to hit a net worth of 10
million it's not because you're just
greedy and trying to gather up money
but it's just you need to be aiming at
something with this investing
otherwise it just seems to be spinning
off into nothingness
and so a clearly defined measurable goal
um and uh just like i want to have my
house paid off by this date
i want to be on a million point five net
worth by that date
you know that kind of a thing and so it
is all about goals
but you ought to really have some
acquisition goals for fun or travel
goals or whatever they want to buy that
sports car
goal for fun and you ought to have some
for generosity do
you know i don't care what is you i want
to fund
missionaries or fund 400 missionaries i
don't care
whatever it is you know but figure it
out and write it down and put a dollar
figure to it and put a time limit on it
and that'll give you your traction back
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage
lauren is with us hey lauren how are you
good how are you
better than i deserve welcome where do
you live carlisle pennsylvania
all right fun what's that near that is
right outside of harrisburg
oh okay cool cool know where you are so
all the way to nashville to do a
debt-free scream how much have you paid
off
seventy four thousand five hundred fifty
five dollars and seventy four cents
there you go how long did this take
21 months yeah and your range of income
during that time
42 000 up to 50 000. wow
okay so what kind of debt was the 75 000
all student loans
whoa what'd you go to school for i have
a bachelor's degree in sociology and a
master's degree in higher education
all right good for you okay what do you
do for a living
i work as a student affairs professional
in higher education ah
good okay and so that income should be
heading right up then
hopefully good
very good okay so did you get out of
school 21 months ago what happened 21
months ago that started this journey
so this really started for me back in
well back when i was a kid actually
um i remember watching my parents
struggle with money so much and i would
have conversations with myself
and i would say whenever you grow up
you're never going to have this fear and
anxiety that you're fearing that you're
feeling right now watching your parents
struggle
so then i grew up went to college
and did everything normal i took out
student loans because i didn't know
anything different
um and then in 2018 um
in like november 2018 right before i was
heading into my last
semester of grad school i remember
talking to my dad and just
saying how fearful i was of these
student loans and that i didn't know how
i was going to make these payments
and he happened to mention your name oh
so it kind of started off from there i
dove into the podcast and i ended up
taking financial peace university in
january of that year
oh wow and then once i graduated in may
i landed a job
and then once i got my job i started
running in june
yeah just going wide open live like a
college student and pay it off yes and
you basically did
35 000 a year for two years is basically
your numbers yeah
and and and hardly made that yeah you've
been on beans and rice
well luckily my mom picked up the pieces
a lot
and let me lived at home for free ah
that helped
nice to have a cheerleader in your
corner very good and some help like that
very very cool so what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
now
i think there's really three things that
drove this home for me the first one is
really know your why
and turn it into a vision every day get
up and visualize what your why is
because that's
gonna that's what's going to drive you
through this problem what was your why
no no anxiety
my why i was remembering that feeling
that i had as a kid and never wanting to
feel that again
yeah that's a good one the second thing
is commit to the plan
just do it stop questioning it no
commitment yes
um and then the third one is believe in
yourself
if you don't believe in yourself it
doesn't it doesn't matter if somebody
else believes in you
or what you're seeing on social media i
actually took a social media hiatus for
a year
because i couldn't take the anxiety of
it yeah that's really powerful lauren
like that those three points are really
really powerful and that could apply to
lots of things right like the believe in
yourself that's really but
one of the things you said that i love
is when you were talking about a little
bit your journey
that you just went to college and did
things normal and i think sometimes
inside this building i'll say you know
for myself dave
i can take for granted that what we do
here is weird it is different when you
go to college it's just
normal to take out loans it's normal to
have credit cards
you don't even question it you didn't
even feel like you were doing anything
wrong you're like oh no this is just
what you do how you go to school
and and gosh good for you for just so
quickly turning around
paying that off doing things weird so
now you can be standing on this stage
completely debt-free of those loans well
done that's impressive
way to go we're proud of you thank you
excellent
excellent job you know the uh i i
have never heard anyone say uh you know
i spend
most of my day on instagram and twitter
and and facebook
and it just gives me such a peace it
makes me feel so good about myself
i'm so peaceful as a result i never have
any i never heard seoul say that ever no
these are not things people say so that
hiatus was a really good idea and
it gives you it allows you to stay
focused and be around you can control
the voices that are coming at you
only have the cheerleaders around get
rid of the debbie downers
and focus and go very well done good
stuff what was the hardest part for you
i thought a lot about this question
preparing for this actually
and my answer isn't the typical it was
budgeting or committing to the plan
for me it was the fact that i had just
left school
and i lived there for six years i had my
i created a new family there
i had everything there and then my job
search actually landed me
going back to my hometown which i was
not prepared for
so i think the hardest part of me was
dealing with these two worlds
these two seasons that would normally be
happening at separate times are now
clashing
so for me it was really taking care of
my mental health and dealing with the
mourning process of everything that i
lost moving back home
yeah and not only back to your own
hometown but you moved back into your
parents
after being away yeah and that's that's
a that's a
that's a a gutsy courageous move because
that's a step
down it was a nice gesture and it was
very generous and it helped you
mathematically
but emotionally that was kind of a punch
wasn't it oh yeah definitely hurt my ego
a little bit yeah
yeah i can imagine i can imagine you're
a sharp young lady
i know your parents are proud of you we
are very very well done
we got a copy of the legacy journey for
you that is the next chapter in your
story for sure
you have a uh you've used this why to
change your life and you'll never have
those
issues around anxiety because now you'll
always tell money what to do
uh and you discovered that it's not when
you got out of debt but when you started
the process of getting out of that the
piece came didn't it
right away yeah pretty quickly as soon
as i start telling the money what to do
i get peace from it i
don't have to get there yet yeah but
yeah very well done
and we're going to give you a copy of
the total money makeover for you to give
away
and uh we'll start somebody else's
journey pay it forward a little bit
so good stuff all right it's lauren from
the harrisburg pennsylvania area
75 000 paid off in
21 months making 42 to 50. what a great
life change count it down let's hear a
debt free scream
three two one i'm debt-free
i love it
you know her other point was what you
believe to be true yeah
and um the old story um dan miller used
to tell the circus elephant
um and i don't know we all heard it
somewhere from somebody but uh
you know you go in there's a bull
elephant that's
you know many many tons could push over
a house
and he's standing there with a rope
a small rope around his ankle and a
small
stake driven in the ground he could
easily just flex that ankle
and that stake would go flying and you
say why would he stand there how can
that rope possibly hold him
and the trainer says well the rope can't
hold him
what holds him is his belief that he can
hold him because when he was a baby
elephant
we put a chain with a big stake right
and around his ankle and he pushed
against it pulled against it to no avail
and now he believes that the chain is
still there yeah
and he can't do it so he won't do it he
won't try it
you know really believing you you might
find that what's holding you back is
just uh is some kind of shadow from the
past
not the reality of the truth and i think
that's what kills people like me and you
when we see people like that stuck
whether it's in their finances or in
some other area of their life with ken
coleman with you know people in careers
they hate they think
well this is just as good as it gets
this is what i have to do this is life
this is my
my car like me can't get ahead
yeah you don't know how my story you
don't know what i've and
you know maybe you don't but gosh it's
like there's so much of it that you can
do that you may not even realize because
of that belief keeping you stuck and
it's just
it's it's painful to watch honestly yeah
and it it's
it's he kind of give it the kind of
german shepherd look though
you know that yeah well how's that rope
holding that elephant how is that
how is it a person that looks like that
and is educated like that
believes they're stuck they're not stuck
right but they believe they are
so tada they are right right and uh
that's a beautiful point that
lauren just made very powerful very
powerful
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
christy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today elena
is with us in lexington kentucky hi
elena how are you
i'm doing well how are you better than i
deserve what's up
okay so thank you so much for taking my
call
um my question is so my husband retired
from the military
in february of 2020 in processing the
retirement paperwork there was an issue
with enrolling in the survivor benefit
program
so it was denied since then we have
appealed to try to overturn the denial
but have not been successful
so the last open enrollment for the sbp
is what they call it
was in 2005 and to have the sbp
it cost six percent of the retirement
income
if we are to buy into the program we
would owe any miss premium so my
question
is should we continue to pursue this no
okay not worth it
no so the goal is for you to get a
portion of his
military retirement upon his death but
what you are paying for that with the
scenario you laid out is outrageous
right not only in lost current benefits
but in the back pay where they're going
to go
back after you on the whole thing no
it's you're fighting for something you
don't even want really at the end of the
day
so what what is his retirement income
uh 3 000 a month okay 36 000
a year all right and how old is he
he is 59. okay what kind of shape is he
in
great shape medically medically good
medically good
yes yes go to zander insurance
dot com and get a term life insurance
policy for four hundred thousand dollars
on him
okay if he dies four hundred thousand
dollars goes into a mutual fund
if it paid ten percent for easy numbers
right now
that would be 40 000 a year which is
more
than his retirement is okay which is 36
000 a year
okay okay so what we're doing is we're
offset
yeah and that term policy will cost you
a whole lot less
than what you're getting ready to pay
for survivor benefits that won't even
amount to three thousand dollars a month
yeah i should okay sure yeah
okay if you so if you only want to buy a
300 or even a 250 000
policy 250 000 be 2 000 a month coming
in if you invested that
at 10 you follow me now here's the other
thing you're not going to keep this
policy forever he's 59 you're probably
going to get it for
five years maybe 10 years something like
that
okay now the uh
because and during that time you're
going to have money in savings that you
would live off of
because you're going to drop that uh
that life insurance policy
when it gets super expensive later okay
but if he's healthy at 59 you'll be
surprised how cheaply you can buy a
couple hundred thousand dollars on him
okay and that's what i would do no you
don't want that survivor benefit
interesting call thank you and tell him
thanks for his service to his country we
appreciate it
so when you sign up for
a pension plan of any kind but certainly
the military uh
you can agree to take a reduced amount
while you're alive
and then your spouse gets the money it
gets a further reduced amount
upon your death or your spouse gets
nothing
and so the survivor benefit is who
survives after the death the
uh of the person that's supposed to be
getting the pension
um and so you can it kind of
you know when you run the numbers back
out the amount you end up getting
what it costs you in reduced benefits
currently usually doesn't work very that
makes sense yeah and usually you're
better off to self-insure through the
death of that person
or buy a policy like a term policy like
we were just talking about
and that gets them out dawn is with us
in phoenix hey dawn how are you
hey dave thanks for taking my call and
thanks for all the advice you give
everybody appreciate it
sure what's up hey so i have um
no debt except for two properties that i
own
one of them's my primary residence and
one of them is a rental property
i'm getting ready to um sell my rental
property
and i'm thinking that i should use all
the proceeds that i
get from this to pay off the mortgage
for my primary residence
yay is that the
move i should make is that a question
should i do this
and what else i mean that's that sounds
brilliant so what do you uh
what's your income um
so jointly we're about 275.
okay and how old are you guys
um i'm 53 and my husband's 55.
okay and so you have this wonderful
income and now you have not a payment in
the world
right and then the other question is
should we
bump up our for our retirement
investment to
like 50 of our income or
what should we do with this extra money
i know we want to invest
you know we're very generous with our
community friends family
you know people in need so just trying
to figure out
how we need to take care of the old
people
us when we get that age somehow i got a
feeling you're going to be all right
but uh the uh you know here's the thing
how much should you're a hundred percent
dead free you've got your emergency fund
how much should i invest and the que
the answer to the question is a question
how wealthy do you want to be
because the more you invest you know i
want to be as wealthy as i can so i can
continue
to you know help others yep so you're
you're
the point is you're the obviously the
more you invest the wealthier you're
going to become right
right and so the more you consume
instead of investing
the less that formula works there's
three things you can do with money when
you get to baby step seven you can give
it
and you should you can enjoy it and
you're better
and you can invest it oh you definitely
better do that one the thing is you need
to put a very specific dollar amount on
your generosity and say
this every year we're going to give away
this percentage
of our income every year we're going to
invest
this percentage of our income every year
we are going to
enjoy this percentage of our income
and that allows you to buy something
silly
guilt-free because it's budgeted
okay because you ought to buy something
silly guilt-free
right you're rich you've been working
hard for a long time
that's very nice that's right you have
yeah you've been working your butts off
you make 275 000
a year you have not a payment in the
world you did it
touchdown do the dance spike the ball
okay it just seems so weird to be at
this point
it is it's a good way i gotta tell you
it is it is an emotional
problem when you get there because it's
almost like you have survivor guilt
like everybody in the plane died but me
why was i spared
you know right and it's like how did i
get here i'm a kid from antioch
tennessee i'm sitting in a
uh you know a 150 million dollar
building
and i paid cash for it how did i get
here i can't get my head around that
emotionally
and yet i do mathematically know how i
got here and i do know the calluses on
my hand and on my brain from all the
hard work i've done to get here
i get all of that but then you still go
holy crap
right i sit here and you freaking utopia
yeah
it's got my name on the outside of it
look sharon it's got our name on it
you know it's like you have these
moments where you don't you survivor
guilty
that kid from antioch inside you know
you're like how do we do it but like you
said dave it's the hard work and i love
that
that advice that's so similar to an
earlier call like what do we do at baby
step seven
you need a new goal a new percentage you
need to know what your vision is in this
new stage it's gonna it's gonna take a
minute to wrap your head around
what this looks like and even feels like
with that that different type of problem
but it's a good
different it's a good kind of problem to
have yeah and
oh by the way um you know just go ahead
and warn you guys
these baby steps like work yeah yeah you
will get there
you're going to have this emotional
problem yeah if you keep doing the stuff
i teach you to do because you're going
to become wealthy
and then you're going to go i just spent
on a car more than i made one year
how and it doesn't even matter it's not
even
close it's just a tink distinctive
you know you can't get your and and you
know and it doesn't even compare to what
we did generosity-wise it doesn't even
compare what we did investment wise
but it still feels weird yeah like oh
this really does work this really does
work we're doing it
yeah expect to have emotional whiplash
when you get there yeah uh you know it
feels like it's an out-of-body
experience
if you get used to it you're kind of
arrogant or weird i'll just go ahead and
tell you
expect the emotional whiplash it goes
with the territory
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show
did you know over 18 million people
listen to the ramsay show every week
and a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country
to find a station near you head to
thermsyshow.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story live from the headquarters of
ramsey solutions broadcasting from the
dollar car rental studios it's the
ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host christy wright ramsey
personality
is my co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life
and about your money jason is with us in
phoenix hi jason welcome to the ramsey
show
hey dave hey chrissy thanks for taking
my call sure what's up
so um me and my spouse we make a
combined
income of uh almost 400 000 a year
wow and i started listening yeah we're
incredibly blessed and we started
listening our show about a year ago
and we've been cranking away on debt but
i i gotta admit i haven't been
completely following the steps
we have been uh continuing to completely
fund
our 401 k during baby step
2 and my question is because of
deferring
taxes should we continue to completely
fund our 401ks
or should we shut that off until we
finish out this last
105 000 in debt
how quickly you're going to finish um
a year and a half okay if not sooner
well i tell people to stop their
retirement temporarily
so what's that going to cost you a year
and a half of investing
um and which is certainly not the end of
the world it's not going to mean that
you are bankrupt
it's not going to mean and if you don't
follow
our guidance and keep doing what you're
doing are you still going to win yeah
you'll still win
that's a year and a half if you're
funding the 401 k it's a year if you
don't right correct
you should pay off a hundred thousand a
year making 400 really
i mean really that leaves you 300 to
struggle through on
barely squeezing out
what kind of debt is it um it's uh
one vehicle one rv and a
uh home equity home equity loan okay
yeah the the point is that um
the the reason you're
ah you're going to be fine either way
and you kind of know that before you
asked right
the reason we tell people to stop even
though
it is mathematically incorrect to
temporarily stop
their retirement savings even if there's
a match while they get out of debt is
simply this personal finance is 80
behavior it's
20 head knowledge and the power of focus
supersedes short-term mathematical gains
and so getting this done
and leaning in with a singular focus
and a growl in your voice when you write
down your budget each month
ah you know that is actually
10 years from today will have made you
more money than what than this one year
of investing would have made you
and so that's the argument and that's
why we tell people to do it
uh because doing three things at once
causes you to get nothing done
now in your case you've got so stinking
much
wood that you can throw on this fire
that the fire's gonna keep burning
anyway you're gonna make it because my
god you just make so much money
i mean you're overwhelming the question
with your income
you know gotcha
and i mean in other words you can get
away with you can get away with screwing
this up
and still come out you're gonna be okay
either way the thing is jason is it's up
to you how long
you want this to last because if you
want to be out of debt in a year
stop your retirement if you want to be
out of debt sooner put more than
whatever you're putting on it you take
the money you're putting in retirement
put that towards your debt
maybe you live on less for a shorter
amount of time
you could be out of debt even faster
it's up to you how quickly do you want
to be out of debt
all right here's the here's the only in
your situation
it's it's a harder argument to make is
what i'm saying but
still philosophically and conceptually
what we teach people to stop stands in
your case maybe there's one other
argument
because you're obviously high
performance people
and me too so
i sometimes will engage in
a behavior that is not necessary for me
to win
because i want new grooves in my brain i
want the old sewage washed out
and so this is like breakthrough
behavior
you know you're shifting your behaviors
you're shifting your habits and
it it kind of pisses you off that you
have to stop this
and it's like this makes me never go
into debt again
and if i kind of play around and wallow
out
i i didn't get the groove in my brain i
didn't get the crap
washed off my brain from the bad way of
doing it this is
this is like a cleansing uh a reset
yeah uh uh you know it's the cold shower
thing you know
yeah uh the the the what are they
calling the cooling pool when you jump
into the coop
you know it shocks the system and resets
and for high performance people that's
necessary well and it's the people that
stand on this debt-free stage that tell
their story
is this visceral never going back
because of the sacrifice they had to go
through to get to that point
and if you don't have that sacrifice if
you don't have some type of man this is
uncomfortable and hard and i'm
a little mad about it then you may go
back that's a good point you may go back
you're like oh and that hard let's do it
again i don't think he's going to go
back but what i'm saying is
it just retrains you it's like i'm the
the
the groove my my habit my my behaviors
are
permanently shifted yeah because i
forced myself through some discomfort
right yeah that's a high performance
activity people that are high
performance do that kind of thing
so that that's um i catch myself doing
that in all kinds of different areas of
my life i'm like
okay i got to break that in order to
break that i got to go over here
and like i got to create an
uncomfortable thing so that never go
back over there yeah
you know and that kind of a deal so
that's kind of where i would throw this
to but
either way dude you're going to be just
fine you keep cranking that guy if you
do either one of these two plans
mathematically you're gonna be fine but
that's the argument
for stopping your retirement temporarily
while you're in baby step two
and the rest of you don't even call me
ask that question cause i'll just tell
you don't do it i'm not going to give
you as much grace i gave him because
you're not making 400 grand
all right get to where you are i'm gonna
just hear it right now i can hear him
dialing up right now
quentin isn't smart you told him hey
click quentin what's up
hey dave hey christy thanks for having
me huge fan of the show
thanks um okay so i have
kind of a two-part question here uh so
earlier this year in february
uh my new bride and i uh were married
um because of the whole kobe thing
obviously we pushed off a larger wedding
ceremony until the summer of this year
um that that's coming up next month
um one of the questions that we've been
struggling with is
uh and we've honestly tried to do the
dave ramsey plan starting with baby step
one
like twice and we've blown through our
emergency fund like twice
only because obviously the wedding's
coming up and we've needed to take care
of some expenses that's not an emergency
that's a piss-poor planning you're
already in trouble with quentin you're
already in trouble
you've already done you know you need to
budget this wedding out it's not an
emergency when you decide
you're going to hire a photographer it's
a decision so you don't touch your
emergency fund for that
so hey hold on we're gonna give you a
wedding gift we'll put you through
financial peace university with a ramsey
plus membership
hold on i'll take care of you we'll get
you straightened out here brother
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
imagine what your income could do for
you
if it wasn't going to somebody in the
form of payments like credit card
companies or student loan companies or
your
car payment what if you had no payments
[Music]
you know what you were just feeling in
your heart you that could really happen
for you
it doesn't have to take as long as you
think it does either you can get there
and get you can get there with financial
peace university it's the class that's
helped over
six million people learn the proven plan
to get out of debt
and become wealthy but it's not enough
just to learn
the plan you've actually got to do the
plan put it in action every day
and the way you do that is by budgeting
with every dollar and you get both
financial peace university and every
dollar
with a ramsey plus membership you can
create a life where your money works
for you not against you it's time to
ditch this debt
fast and for good start your free trial
at ramsey plus
by texting trial to 33
789 a free trial by texting trial
two three three seven eight
nine christie ryan ramsey personality is
my co-host
open phones at triple eight eight two
five 825-5225
louise is in akron ohio hi louise how
are you
hi dave and christy thank you for taking
my call sure what's up um
i have a question about starting a roth
after retiring
my situation is i have a little over a
hundred thousand in a 457.
i'm 56 i retired a couple years ago
and i don't plan on needing it anytime
soon
so i wanted to about take out about ten
thousand a year
from it and put that in a lot of 450
strain of roth
so that it grows tax-free the 457 plan
sent me the paperwork for it but they
also sent me a lot of information
about how i make more in the 457 because
their fees are lower
so is moving some of it to a roth a good
idea
what's it invested in in the 457
it's invested in um a couple
of what they call it large cap mid cap
and small cap funds what kind of what
kind of returns have you been getting
i've been getting some pretty good
returns i'm averaging about 12 percent
yeah okay that's about what you should
be able to do
good okay so i i don't know that they're
correct on the fees i think that's
probably just them trying to protect
their
accounts their portfolio but um
i don't think you're going to gain a
huge amount by moving money
out of this uh to an ira in the in
mutual funds that perform similarly
i think you're going to have about a
break even there the only thing you
could have
is the money from this point forward
could grow
tax-free however you're going to have to
pay taxes on whatever you move
so do you have some extra money that's
not this account
what they do is they will hold 20 of it
no
that's not that they don't either uh
that's not up to you
that's that's if you withdraw it if you
withdraw it they withhold 20
but that's not going to be their option
you can roll the whole thing to a
traditional ira
and they don't withhold a dime then when
you roll it from a trigger
then when you roll it from a traditional
they're not allowed to withhold on that
that's a true that's a direct transfer
rollover okay indoor traditional enough
to cover
i would have enough to cover the taxes
on about 10 000 a year
okay if you roll it all to a traditional
get with a smartvestor pro
put it in similar mutual funds you're
going to make about the same money
and if you roll 10 000 a year out you're
going to have about a 2500
tax bill on that you can go you're going
to cash flow that tax bill that's what
you're saying right
yes correct so you don't have any other
money
yeah i've got an emergency fund and some
other money
in a fun for like home repairs car
repairs
okay and are you working uh your encore
career after you retire
because you're young yes right yes i'm
running a small farm
okay so what kind of money are you
making there
uh not a lot last year i grossed about 3
000
but i'm having the time of my life
yeah okay so i want you to start making
some money while you're having the time
of your life too okay
uh okay yeah let's let's get a little
better business model i'll turn you over
to christy on the farm here
uh she's also someone who's lost money
on a farm
i'm with you louise i was having a lot
of fun a lot of work but a lot of fun
yes you know in addition to everything
dave's talking about i'll send you my
book business boutique uh woman's guide
for making money doing what she loves
it you can do both you can have you can
have fun
you can play enjoy the farm and also
make some income that will help take the
pressure off give you some options
and uh just get that income up a little
bit so we'll send you that as well yeah
here's the reason i'm pushing you on
that okay number one you're young and
you've got a lot
a lot of time left a lot of runway left
to
on-ramp to go do something big and fun
make some money number two you kind of
need to 100 000 bucks in that much money
true so your nest egg's not huge
and uh i would love for it to be if you
told me if you had a million in there
and you wanted to
goof off on the farm and make no money
we can talk about it but i need you to
grow this nist egg for you
and uh screwing around with ten thousand
dollars is not
fixing this um adding tens of thousands
of dollars into your investments every
year is going to fix it
and get this thing up and that's going
to require income so
that's what i would tell you to do is
work on this side of the equation too
hold on we'll have madison pick up we'll
send you a copy of christy's book
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five rachel is in california hi
rachel welcome to the ramsey show
hi what an honor to talk to you both
thank you for taking my call
sure what's going on my question today
for you
is um me and my husband um we have about
fifty thousand dollars
in a savings account in the bank um it
was going to be used towards me going to
school
however we had a child he's about a year
now
and i'm a stay-at-home mom and my
husband loves being the breadwinner
i'm itching to go back to work i'm
itching to go back to school
but he wants to use that 50 000 um
that we have to start a business and
he's always had businesses
and in this case he wants to start a
trucking business
and we we both really just need some
wisdom and guidance
what to do next
hmm this is this is interesting rachel
this is an interesting question because
uh this isn't as much about money as it
is about values
what you want to do with the money
versus what he wants to do with the
money so i'm curious if you uh go back
to work what do you what do you do what
do you want to do
i'm a veterinary technician and i would
be going back to that
and the money was going to be for
veterinary school which is i understand
a huge commitment with a child and even
just to go back to work would be great
but i want to respect what my husband
wants for the family structure
yeah this is a
this is a conversation that i think
would be so beneficial to have
with a counselor not because y'all are
broken and your marriage is
having a hard time but sometimes it can
be so helpful to have a third party walk
through
what are his fears of you going back to
work what are his desires what are your
desires to go back to work what are your
fears around money and that type of
thing and dig to the deeper layers going
on in this conversation that
that i believe is a lot more than just
financial but here's the here's the key
both of you need to be heard both of you
need to be
a participant both of you need to be
respected he does need to
be respected as do you rachel both of
you need to be respected heard
seen and both of you need to speak into
the decision
if you do something that
makes you concede
your life in the name of
respecting his view of the structure of
the family
that is creates an unhealthy
relationship 10 years from today you
will resent it
that's not going to work you can only
hold your breath so long
so it needs to be where both of you have
worked this thing through and you went
you know what
i like that i don't like it as much as b
but i like a
and let's go do this and uh there's
you know you're gonna both of you are
going to concede something but where you
just say
well i'm going to completely walk away
from what i care about my dreams my
thing
because of his view of the family
structure
yeah that sounds bad when you just when
you say that
yeah so um i i think that the the
beautiful music is made when both of you
can play your instruments loud
and um and even if they're not in
perfect harmony
but at least you're both playing them
loud so i think christie's right on
seeing someone and having them help you
unpack that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
brad and marisa are with us in new haven
connecticut it says on my screen you
guys are
debt free congratulations
thank you hi dean hey how much have you
guys paid off
we've paid off 88 608 dollars and 27
cents
awesome way to go how long did that take
that took us 22 months wow and your
range of income during that time
uh 140 000 up to 175.
good awesome what do you guys do for a
living
i'm in finance and i was a teacher now
i'm a
stay-at-home mom and a freelance
writer cool yeah and
uh good so what kind of debt was the 89
000
oh we had it all uh two car loans 401k
loan
student debt medical bills and of course
credit cards
of course you guys were like normal how
long y'all been married 10 years
13. 13 almost like i guessed it right
good
okay so after uh
11 years of marriage you looked up 22
months ago and said something's got to
change
tell us the story what happened yeah
absolutely
we were just sick and tired of living
paycheck to paycheck
and especially not knowing where all our
money was going at the end of the year
yeah the the end of the month was always
like where did it go we had no idea and
then um
dave viewer a guest on another podcast
that we
both listened to and he came home from
work one day and said hey did you
yeah this guy dave ramsey was was on and
i really like what he had to say and
asked if i can grab the total money
makeover the next time i went to the
library
and i had said oh i heard that today too
and i really liked it so i'll get the
book and i'll read it with you
and the next day we got the total money
makeover read it
and oh gosh maybe two days
and we drank the kool-aid
cool who's podcast uh you were on ben
shapiro's
sunday special oh yeah yeah yeah
good yeah ben and i ben and i have
become friends since then that's very
nice oh that's awesome
he's a great guy he's a great guy their
whole team just moved to uh to nashville
to get out of california just a little
while
yeah well cool
way to go guys that's so fun i'll have
to tell him that happened he'll like
hearing that
so 89 000 later the total money makeover
told you how to do it you go and do it
right
we did talk a little bit about what this
was like in your marriage because y'all
been married for over a decade when you
started this plan
talk a little bit about what it was like
to to work as a team and have such an
intense goal
yeah absolutely um this is probably the
biggest thing for imagine
our marriage too is just having the
joint commitment
to to tackle this and change our
spending behavior
and especially change our family tree
wow it all started off
with you know us coming together reading
this book
like we said drank the kool-aid and then
we uh sat down together
for the first time did a monthly budget
and together
you know we took that first step on on
this new lifestyle change
yeah good for you i would say it
actually uh you know we
we've been through quite a lot in 13
years and but i would say that this was
probably
um just brought us
so much closer than any of the other
things we've done over the years
yeah it does it's really it's it's it's
just amazing in that
sense what it did for our marriage yeah
the only way to pull it off is to work
together and the only way to work
together is to
be more unified than you've ever been so
yeah it's a pretty pretty intense
transformative process for sure
what do you tell people what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
i just like brad said just the joint
commitment
and being willing and able to to make
those changes especially in your
behavior doing it together
and communicating your goals and
your you know hopes for the future and
we've done a lot of those dream meetings
over the last two years and and that's
and of course the budget the budget's
huge because we never did that before
when we when we wrote out our debts i
put it on like this
little drawing i made it like a big
brick wall you know smallest to largest
and just staring at it you're like this
is going to take forever but
you got to take the first step and it
happened a lot faster than we thought
and i know you preached that too on your
show and it's true
but it still feels when you're at the
beginning like oh god this is going to
take forever
yeah yeah yeah it's a huge mountain
sitting in front of you eighty nine
thousand dollars worth yeah
yeah we thought it was it was going to
take
a long time it was very daunting yeah
what was the hardest part what was the
hardest part that the dauntingness
i think it was actually the hustle
marisa
also did waitressing to help accelerate
this payoff
so we would just be passing each other i
would come home from work and she'd be
on our way out
and you know we have three young kids so
uh no breaks
we went since so i think just getting at
it that was that was hard
and we did that for for a while um but
it paid off in the end so it could have
taken a lot longer
but that's right she's a tough woman so
she got after it yeah we didn't see each
other much
yeah well you increased your income
thirty five thousand dollars during this
time
had to you know unless somebody just got
some inordinate raises you guys have
been after it that's pretty cool
we hustled well that's what it takes and
uh the good news is now that you're free
how's it feel now that you're free
oh my gosh i think for me the freedom
was
was the biggest part and that really um
hit me um
back in the fall when it was time for
schools to reopen and our school
district was
so wishy-washy and they're going back
they're not and
at that point we were on our last debt
and our snowball was big enough where we
were able to
still you know make our snowball
payments but also
cash flow private school for our oldest
daughter for the year and
i felt like this is what freedom feels
like this is
you know i'm not not um
yeah using debt to support it or just
not knowing how we're supporting it just
doing it yeah
and just being able to to know that we
didn't have to be at the mercy
of you know teachers unions or
politicians
it was a big like that so that for me
was was i think when it really hit
that like wow look what we can do yeah
money money has no
value at all except what it will do and
one thing
it does is it gives you options yes that
you don't have if you don't have money
and you had options you could reach over
to a private school keep the kid rolling
and
uh you know uh you know you you can
avoid this
that's one of the reasons that the
pandemic had such a hard time the heart
the hardest people hit in the pandemic
the economic suppression from the
pandemic was the uh folks on the bottom
rungs
i mean you know who who got who lost
their job so it wasn't white collar
executives on wall street
they didn't lose their jobs who lost
their jobs were the maids
at the hotel because the hotel was
closed down the waitresses
you know but you you're waiting tables
you saw it and
those those restaurants closing up those
are the people the people that could
least afford
to lose their jobs were the ones that
lost their jobs it was a horrible
thing a horrible inequality
of how the economic suppression brought
on by the governments and this
how it affected everybody so anyway
enough of that way to go you guys i'm so
proud of you
so proud of you we got a copy of the
legacy journey for you
that is the next chapter in your story
for sure you have changed and set your
legacy
it is a new thing for you so proud of
you also got a copy of total money
makeover because that's what changed you
guys and now you can give it to somebody
when they ask and they say oh read this
and i'll give you an extra copy to give
away
and i'm glad i'm glad the book was there
to help you in the podcast and
everything else
brad and marissa 89 000
paid off in 22 months making 140 to 175
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is how it's done that's awesome wow
wow wow great job
great job
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture of the day ecclesiastes 10
10 if the axe
is dull and its edge unsharpened
more strength is needed but skill
will bring success john maxwell says
small disciplines repeated with
consistency every day
lead to great achievements gained slowly
over time open phones at triple eight
eight two five
five two two five j is in orlando hi jay
how are you
hey dave hey christy how are you guys
today better than i deserve how can we
help
that's great so um i have an i hope a
unique question
i wrote um so i'm a cyber security
architect and i wrote a
framework similar to your baby steps for
cyber security addiction cyber no sorry
cyber addiction
and um i want to know what to do with it
next you know as
cyber guys we are always writing like
root cause analysis
and i wrote that i wrote a cause a
condition and a cure
and it's very there's a lot of parallels
to your baby steps and that kind of
thing and it
kind of like i got it like i've figured
out what to say
now i got to get people to say it to you
so i wanted to call and ask
what you would recommend who's it for
people that are addicted more
specifically than that
right i mean like what's the what's your
persona
sorry uh so the groups would be um so
family like used to do a lot of pastoral
counseling is javelin
families interpersonal marriages just
people
right people the way things are working
now with a lot of
applications there's a lot of addiction
type
like uis that are being created where
where it's kind of like you walk in the
front end of a casino right
and there's lots of things going on
there's i don't want to get too geeky on
you but
um there's there's this psychometric
mapping
that um anyway i've got a way to prove
all that i got a way
to help people out of that um i got a
method very similar like
i came down and i said can i can i
figure out what happened
can i figure out how it's changing
people and then can i figure out how to
actually help them get out
and i got something in terms of uh cyber
addiction are we talking
i'm a little bit just a little more
clarification are you talking about like
uh people addicted to online porn
are you talking about people just
addicted to checking their facebook 73
000 times a day or playing games on
their apps or something great
great question so actually it's my
opinion
that in all those cases the same thing
is happening in all those cases right
it's like being addicted to food or
addicted to anything else there's still
there's a
there's a change that occurs with a
um high adherence to any type of ui
like that so your your mind is being
remapped no matter what
so um i think the cause the the cure
would be
uh very similar in all those well i
think the reason i ask the question is i
think not
not about the the process but what i'm
trying to get clarification on is
your customer base is different if
you're going after people that are
addicted to porn
than if you're going after 52 year old
women who can't get off of facebook
that's that's why i was asking who's
your market like who's
who are you specifically creating this
for i would start out with families
okay the the first questions that i get
most of the time is
i can't connect with my kids anymore so
they're they got their nose buried in a
that's what you know it could be like
with young
adolescent males that there's a lot of
porn going on right now and there's a
lot of
push towards there it's like prevalent
but when you're talking with
um teenage girls right it's a different
thing right and if you look at the whole
family unit really everybody's got their
hook
everybody's got their different from
fathers like me to
um you know everybody so um i i would
approach it from the family point of
view
first of all i think that's the way i
would do it but okay
what what you're going to struggle with
is you're you need to
in order to get this to market you need
to narrow your persona
um we've asked you the question three
different ways and we've gotten broad
answers every time
i want to get this to families
you know that's just too broad so you
need to say i want to get those families
that are doing x y and z
yeah okay that have families that are
disconnected that aren't having
conversations with their kids
what what that's all families yeah
that's all families but built
but building that out from even a income
level
a psychographic geographic however you
want to
and then you'll know how to talk to them
because where to find them
yeah where to find them because that's
the trick is is um
i mean the irony is is that you'll
probably find them online
yeah yeah you know you may you may be
doing some blogging you may be doing
some stuff to get their attention
uh and then with keywords and then set
that out into the facebook universe and
out into the
uh google universe and and begin to pull
back with seo
but um but again you need to be
targeting
something more specifically than you are
and the person in the family that's
going to do something about it so
either and it could be it doesn't have
to be a certain gender just just moms or
just dads
but but pick a person that you're
speaking to the one that is motivated to
fix this problem because
what's interesting about your situation
jay with this specific problem is
many people have this problem and don't
know it's a problem
ironically they do with money as well
they have a money problem they don't
know that they do
is this something telling them they have
a problem is this something you get to
the marriage counseling community the
pastoral counseling community and then
they
deliver it to their uh constituents
um or are you going direct to the
consumer and if you're the more you're
going to go direct to the consumer the
more you're going to have to decide
exactly who it is
at least for the first wave right you
can broaden it later
yeah but for the first wave um you know
for the first wave of
financial piece the book uh we were not
going after
uh 65 year olds
back then in 1994 65 year olds
most of them had common sense and the
book was about common sense i'm not sure
i could say that today about 65 year
olds but
the ones from 30 years ago yeah uh
you know that are now 90 uh had common
sense yeah
and uh so i was not going after them i
was going after the 34 year old mom
sitting in a car pool line with student
loan debt credit card debt
and i had a fight with her husband about
the money and so that's that's what
christie means about a persona now
once i know that she's the target then
that changes the content message
the uh the narrative that you use and
you know where to locate them
uh you know where where do you find a 34
year old mom sitting in a
carpool line uh you know and where do
you find
a 65 year old white male you know i
don't need him and so
i don't need that's a rush limbaugh
listener uh
when rush was alive you know and uh no
disrespect or anything but i just
know that that's not my market right and
that's not where we're going with it
right and so who are we trying to help
and then we're going to get it
very narrow and go straight to them
and then that'll help you locate the
pool of potential prospects yeah let me
give you something real specific and
tactical that you can do jay because it
sounds like to me that you're in the
early stages of this it's still somewhat
theory i know you said you have steps
and you have a plan and it's proven it
will work and so on
i think that's great what i want you to
do is take that to market on a really
small
kind of experimental research basis so
reach out to anybody you know that could
be family
friends your church workplace community
facebook i don't care just people that
you know
that fall within the general target
market of who you're trying to help
maybe some families that represent
you know that ideal customer and i want
you to take them through it
maybe it's for free just for feedback
and then as you walk them through this
framework have them go through the plan
you're gonna get testimonials
you're gonna get feedback on things that
need to change you'll learn more about
your messaging how they describe it
we'll give you some words to put to it
of how you can describe it to more
people
it will also give you a base to start to
ask for referrals and word of mouth it's
a very organic way to start
as you're getting this thing to market
and then you can get a little more
sophisticated
through online marketing whether that's
through social media or
other paid marketing that type of thing
uh once you get your language right
but that you need to have real people
help you with the language of how they
talk about it so you can talk about how
they talk about it so just start with
start with what you have the people that
you know take some people through it
that'll give you some feedback
to begin to grow it a little bit now the
language
that the customer uses is more important
than the language that you think they
should use
yes actually that informs everything we
do yeah
the words that they use and how they use
them and how they truncate
um some of your thoughts into single
words
yes and that kind of a thing and so
that's what you're looking for because
that that causes you to build your
content and your narrative out there
so very interesting discussion jay it
sounds like you're onto something sounds
like it's needed for sure
oh i know it's needed don't don't lay it
down uh but let's get it narrow enough
that you can get it off the ground
that it has some power and some oomph so
good question sir christy good hour
thanks it's great good job to james
childs and kelly daniels in the booth
i'm dave ramsey your host will be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace
christ jesus
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section
or head to the ramsay show.com thanks
for listening
you